[Music]
we spent all of 1997 crushing on Leo
because of Titanic and and I was of
course bopping and with my hairbrush in
the mirror back in when I was we're just
gonna leave that at that but Henson is
celebrating 25 years of performing
together and et Sophie she lacy caught
up with the guys we've been all over the
world since basically May we've been
going nonstop since 92 practically when
we started now 32 the youngest brothers
Zach was just six when they formed the
band two decades in the business and you
guys still get Fant like crazy fan
reactions I think it would have to be
really hard on your wives to put in that
position
did they struggle with all the screaming
girls well no they're all like we won
[Laughter]
Isaac and Zach both been married 11
years
Taylor's celebrating 15 I mean all our
wives in some form and other at shows
Wow
also all know that the reason why we met
them was because they weren't like
screaming and throwing themselves yeah
and there could be another generation of
Hansons making music between the three
of them the brothers have 12 kids and
they got them to star in a recent music
video
are any of them showing an interest in
show business yet
Isaac's oldest signing is playing guitar
yeah Taylor's oldest son is playing
keyboard and my oldest son is just
started playing drums if somebody didn't
pursue music and like between our kids I
would be surprised 2017 is a huge year
for the tour
The Greatest Hits albums a Christmas
album
yes we usually giving another is to week
during the holidays they'll probably be
thrown back a few cold ones they have
their own line of beer called hops get
it and we played a really fun game of
truth or drink with them and you can
only check it out by going to eat you
online
[Music]